the war did not come to Westeros with
men in the dawn of days the children of
the forest fought to the drives but
neither race sought to destroy the other
or they claimed to the continent they
couldn't the children hunted and fought
with dragonglass arrows and Spears and
the Giants had only the branches that
poured from trees
nor could both races feel more than one
of the Seven Kingdoms of today then the
southern deserts coughed up a new race
the first men were crossed the Narrow
Sea over the arm of Dorne
unlike the children trials the first men
lived in huts and villages and farmed
the land to eat and there were so many
as the numbers swelled men needed ever
more fields and timber of course they
saw that the great forests could provide
both when they're cut into the deep
woods however they stumbled on a strange
sight the white tree with red leaves and
a face staring back at them
at first they were afraid but a face
never spoke even when the axe bit into
it the first men didn't know what a
weirwood was they didn't know that a
rare wood grows forever if left in peace
or that the native children believe
their spirits went into it after death
the children had no letters ruins all of
the history songs and prayers only the
trees remembered when the children
looked at the cleared fields they saw
not white stumps but their ancestors now
lost forever with a bones stolen to line
the invaders walls driven mad by grief
the children attacked the first men had
never seen the weirwood but the children
had never seen bronze the dragonglass
arrows glanced off the first immense
fields and their armor of woven box
flipped beneath the first men's swords
as the war raged the children resorted
to the one advantage they had the magic
of the old gods their greenseers
enlisted direwolves and snow bear's cave
lions and eagles mammoths and socrates
in return the first men cut down and
burned everywhere would do they could
find fearing that the children would spy
on them through the faces of the trees
the children became desperate that
weensy has cooled down the hammer of
waters to break the arm of Dorne
destroying the bridge that meant crossed
into Westeros and to flood to the neck
to contain men to the south but the
first men would not be stopped fearing
extinction the children combined their
powers for one last spell
that would save their people and their
land from the invaders by themselves the
children were too few to resist the
onslaught but if they could turn men's
numbers against them after hundreds of
years and untold deaths and destruction
the wisest heads of the children and the
first men finally prevailed the children
couldn't win this war the first men
didn't want to win
fearing the costs of victory heroes and
rulers and both sides met upon an isle
in the kansai to form the packets the
children gave up all the lands of
Westeros save for the deep forests and
the first men swore that they would no
longer cut down the wear woods thus
ended the drawn age and began the Age of
Heroes yet after the dawn must come the
night the great evil that the children
unleashed in the war returned centuries
later and only an alliance between the
children and men defeated it now it
comes again when the children are a
shadow or what they were and men have
long forgotten but the trees remember
and Brandon stark must learn or as we
watched the first men so we will watch
the lost
you